elles sont partout belle colleront
majestueux mais il y en a tellement
qu'on finit avec le temps par ne puis
remarquer de plus en plus de russes se
pose sérieusement la question pourquoi
le clergé continue d'en construire avec
frénésie y compris dans son quartier
[Musique]
nous sommes sur le chantier de ce qui
sera bientôt une les quatre nouvelles
églises de zouzou en banlieue de moscou
je ne chante i comme celui ci il y en a
plus de 200 dans la région de moscou
seulement explique sergen tanovic un
projet que mène main dans la main le
patriarche toute la russie et le
gouvernement qui lui offre gratuitement
des terrains vacants
la majorité des églises sont au centre
explique sergey et les banlieues comme
la nôtre ont très peu de lui un héritage
du régime soviétique qui lisent soit
rasé où on a interdit la construction
martin qu'il faisait et le porte parole
du patriarche de l'église orthodoxe de
la russie depuis la chute de l'urss a
construit ou retaper plus de 30 mille
églises dans les anciennes républiques
et prévoit maintenant en ériger des
milliers d'autres
la nôtre ce sera blanche qui aura 4
coupole dorée un jardin d'hiver dit
servier ça va coûter une fortune mais en
attendant les gros sous on peint sur
chacune de ces briques le nom de petits
donateurs du coup j'ai fait abstraction
ce sont souvent des compagnies
étroitement lié au gouvernement tout
comme les 2010 orthodoxe de toute la
russie depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de
vladimir poutine
les de cette génération qui n'a plus
peur de s'exprimer et qui en a surtout
marre du diktat des autorités de
l'église et des oligarques qui la
finance
l'exemple de la ville de 10,4 un bourg
est sans doute le plus éloquent
en mai dernier les résidents de la ville
de l'oural ont manifesté jour et nuit
pour stopper la construction d'une
église en plein coeur de ce parc un
projet financé exclusivement par un
milliardaire de l'industrie c'est
vraiment beau jean françois thiery
l'observateur religieux au silence du
clergé est un symptôme de ce que
l'église est devenue en russie une
complice du pouvoir
will a perdu un petit peu ce rôle de
d'autorité morale pour moi ekaterinbourg
c'est un peu la même chose au ccrct
société civile qui a dit oui d'accord
vous avez besoin d'église parce que vous
avez eu lieu pour pouvoir prier etc mais
n'exagérons pas étonnamment si le
président vladimir poutine lui-même qui
a ordonné le gel des travaux le temps de
consulter la population
une victoire mais temporaire qui risque
d'inspirer d'autres manifestations dans
un pays où les églises poussent comme
des champignons en creuse ça le club ni
moi ni mise n y allons à l'église et
c'est complètement fou d'en ajouter une
autre dit cet étudiant
mais ici azzouzi nos c'est trop tard aux
travaux avancent et personne ne m'a
demandé mon opinion dit cette maman elle
aurait de loin opté pour un parc ou une
aire de jeu
et ce malgré le fait que le nombre de
russes qui vont à la messe soit en
déclin à peine 6%
toute la population selon les plus
récentes données